Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
in my Walking Dead US Video I asked you to
submit all your questions about the finale,
Terminus, Beth and everything else.
I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
and one bonus question.
Generally we’re all wondering if Barbecue
Beth is going to be on the menu and who else
is going to die.
First thing’s first though.
Congratulations to Chloe Fynn, you’re the
winner of this week’s giveaway.
I’ll be ‘DMing you on your channel for
details.
Next week I’ll be giving away two gift cards.
I’ll also be doing more season 5 predictions
videos this week.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
if you’re finding me for the first time.
So let’s answer some questions.
Careful for spoilers from episode 15 and everything
in the comics up to The Hunters if you’re
not caught up.
Here we go,
Question 1 - Guardians 3000 asks What did
Glenn and Tara use to lure the walkers to
the one side of the tunnel?
They just used the Flash light to cast a shadow
on the wall.
It was hard to see, but the Wallkers were
attracted to the bright light and the motion.
Which explains why in episode 9 when Michonne
had her Walker pets, and was walking in that
big group of them, they didn’t turn on her.
So, if the virus ever breaks out be sure to
take these notes down.
Walk slowly simulating the movements of any
Walkers around you, and they may not notice
you.
No Guarantees.
Question 2 - Gabby Chestnut asks Do you think
that Maggie and Glenn burning her picture
is foreshadowing?﻿
Yes, absolutely.
Maggie has been one of the people I think
is most likely to die in the finale.
I already mentioned how romance is a death
sentence on the show.
But she is not a clear thinker, nor is Glenn.
That impulsiveness is probably going to get
her into trouble in the finale.
We don’t know whether the people who took
Beth are hostile or not.
Everyone is getting Hunter vibes, but they
could just as easily be non-cannibal villains.
Question 3 - Macsization asks Why are Rick's
hands covered in blood in the teaser for the
next episode?
That’s probably just a follow up on the
visual teaser of Tony looking at that Candy
Wrapper on the railroad tracks.
Rick will at the very least, end up in a fight
with Joe’s group.
Then there’s still the wild card of the
people at Terminus.
There wasn’t anyone at the gate, but there
was a sign that said lay down your weapons
or you’ll be met by force.
So there have to be more people there somewhere.
Rick looked like most of his Governor beating
had healed.
But he’s still squishy, so while I think
he’ll have to fight Joe’s men.
I don’t think it will be as brutal as his
brawl with the Governor.
And there’s the added bonus of having Daryl
to help him.
Question 4 - Dominique Lionsdale asks do you
think we’ll learn what happened to Beth
in the finale?
Yes, I saw a lot of you guys commenting on
whether or not they’d show her in the finale.
We haven’t gotten any answers since she
was kidnapped.
And there’s a laundry list of people that
could have taken her, from bandits, to Gareth
to Hunters.
I feel like if they had already revealed what
happened to her before the finale.
Things would be half as stressful.
Which is a good thing, from the writer’s
standpoint.
I don’t know about you guys, but I will
go crazy if I don’t find out if she’s
okay.
So I’m forced to watch next week.
Not that I wouldn’t watch if everything
were reversed.
Even if the finale weren’t as good as last
year it would still be a lot of fun.
That being said, the candelight vigil for
Beth starts Saturday night.
Question 5 - PickAHand asks What the hell
Maggie?﻿ Why hasn’t she expressed more
concern about Beth?
I also have seen a disturbing lack of concern
over Beth from everyone except Daryl.
I think there’s a couple of reasons Maggie
hasn’t said anything about it yet.
First, she probably felt like Beth was in
good company when they parted ways at the
prison.
Two, she was forcibly separated from Glenn.
So she had no idea what he was doing when
they got split up.
She knew Beth got on the bus and got away.
She’s also probably thinking about Beth,
and just not saying anything out loud.
It’s not like she’s had a ton of lines
this half of the season.
And lastly, they could be building her character
up for a big reveal.
For instance, we’ve established Maggie is
a little crazy.
What if something bad happened to Beth and
Maggie reacts violently.
If she’s the one that’s going to die,
Beth could be the macguffin that leads to
that.
Question 6 - Manuel Cortez asks Do you think
that Daryl will find out Joe’s group is
hunting for Rick before they find him?
No, I think he’ll be totally surprised.
It makes for a better oh shit reaction.
Because he’d be stunned that his friend
is still alive and at the same time Tony will
be trying to “claim him” with his assault
rifle.
Remember how that other redneck stole Daryl’s
rabbit kill.
He shot first and asked questions later.
Something tells me the rest of those guys
are just like that.
And Daryl will be forced to choose between
the outdoor cats and the indoor cats while
all that is happening.
Let it be said though, does anyone think for
a minute that Daryl wouldn’t choose his
friends over the marauders?
It really depends on what happened to Beth.
If she’s still alive, she’ll swing him
in the right direction.
Question 7 - Josh Redgrave asks When the show
ends for ever how would you like it to end?﻿
So all the time people are leaving, because
the die and people are coming.
Like Abraha, Eugene and Rosita.
I think the show should end when the last
of the original cast is alone.
Everyone else from season 1 is dead and this
last person has to re-form a new group somewhere.
They’ve never hinted that there might actually
be a cure, a real cure.
So by that logic, humanity will just slowly
converge and either die off or just hold their
ground indefinitely.
The numbers aren’t promising, so everyone
on the planet will probably be dead inside
of 50 years unless they cure the virus.
I think it ending in a really depressing,
this is just the way it’s going to be moment
would be appropriate.
Something that would let you know that even
though that one last character is alive with
other new people.
Humanity in general is doomed in the long
run.
Walking Dead is a show of attrition, for everyone
one new person that comes one, it seems like
two people die.
Question 8 - I’m the Donut asks Do you think
that Morgan will be involved in the finale?
I think it’s still too soon for him to come
back.
Scott Gimple said he would re appear, but
not this season.
So next year or later.
But he’ll definitely come back at some point.
I think Gareth is the real character behind
Terminus.
For better or worse.
We still don’t know if he’s a villain.
Question 9 - joe kerr asks K Do you think
the painting that Carl found was a painting
of Mary?﻿
Someone on reddit actually connected the dots.
But yes, the person in the painting looks
exactly like Mary.
Which means that was probably her family in
the pink room.
It lends credence to the fact she’s a little
crazy and we just won’t find out till it’s
too late.
Hopefully that mystery meat she’s serving
up isn’t what we think it is.
Question 10 - Maddie Hall asks Do you think
they are eating Beth?
So this could go down a number of ways.
If they are hunters, and they’re paying
homage to the comics, then they wouldn’t
be eating Beth, they’d just be eating her
leg.
In the comics it was Dale, who had been bitten
by a walker when that happened.
And Beth was just kidnapped.
She didn’t get bitten.
So no matter what, they’d have to change
a few things about that part of the story.
I really hope they’re not hunters.
Or if they are Hunters, they just have her
tied up somewhere.
With all her limbs firmly attached.
Bonus Question - Laurent asks Why do you think
the doors of the terminus and the whole thing
wasn't really secured?
I think they have people ready with weapons
in case something goes wrong.
And it’s in a nice open area, so you’d
be able to see Walkers approaching from a
long way away.
That sign said lay down your weapons or you’ll
be met by force.
It think next week we’ll meet the force.
So thanks so much for submitting questions,
next Sunday it all goes down.
I’ll be doing a season 5 predictions video
sometime this week, be sure to subscribe to
get it.
And now that Walking Dead is almost over,
let me know what kind of videos you want to
see me do for it until it comes back.
Like the Game of Thrones videos I do, or something
else.
Be sure to let me know.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my Lizzie WTF video.
That will be a good episode to re-visit in
the off season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow,
high fives!